now get ready for the latest entry into
the nothing is too personal world of
reality TV five families including
Lindsay Lohan's parents Dina and Michael
are airing their dirty laundry for all
to see in family therapy but the
question is just off the ratings or can
this show really help these fractured
families never take cocaine and I didn't
do it
Kenzi I don't know that birthday after a
while there's no cameras around and
there's no mics on you forget they're
there and when you're in treatment
that's when you're very reactionary it's
raw and intense one house no cell phones
no TV and the cameras roll 24/7 do I do
this on television
just close the door in the past bring
awareness to domestic abuse and move
forward and helping him builds a better
relationship with our four children
there was mental and physical abuse
you're a pathological liar divorced in
2007 the loewen's have plenty to work
through as do the rest of their
housemates reality stars like Bam
Margera and his mom and Teen Mom Brianna
day Zeus and her sister Brittany the new
vh1 series family therapy with dr. Jenn
is sometimes out of control and it was a
real big slap in the face that's how you
man
but is having a national audience for
this really a good idea it is according
to dr. Jen man the show's resident
therapist I can play back a tape and say
look at how you talk to her look at how
you talk to him did you realize how you
came off I have resources here that
allow me to do therapy on such a deep
and profound level it's hard for people
to even understand we have resources
here you could never have a private
practice the fact that we have cameras
here we we have security here we have
multiple therapists here they are having
this experience around-the-clock makes
it possible for them to do therapy my
family's all undergo three weeks of
therapy to see if they can rebuild the
relationships or you see it as time to
come time